thank you well it's a great pleasure to
be here and participate in the symposium
on how neurons and circuits of neurons
compute and I have always the question
that's always interested me most about
neural circuits is how they use their
plasticity to way they their
computational performance and here I'm
using the term compute to mean transform
an input into an output so my lab is
focused on the question of what are the
algorithms that neural circuits use to
do their way what are the rules and we
know that individual synapses don't know
what's happening in the world but
they're making a local decision about
whether to change or stay the same based
on the pattern of input they experience
so my lab is interested in better
understanding the local rules that
synapse is used to make these decisions
and ultimately how those decisions are
coordinated or at least work together
across a circuit to define an algorithm
for tuning the circuits performance and
we have some clues about this from the
work that's been done over many years in
brain slices where we know for example
about hebbian plasticity whereby cells
that fire together tend to wire together
coincident activity in a pre and
postsynaptic neuron can induce changes
in the synapse connecting Matt neuron
those two neurons and we also know about
spike timing dependent plasticity which
can alter synapses in opposite
directions potentiation or depression
depending on whether the presynaptic
neuron fires just before or after the
postsynaptic neuron and these two
general rules these two ideas about
plasticity hebbian and spike timing
dependent plasticity have shaped a lot
of the work on learning and memory
including the work in my lab but today I
want to focus on some of the ways in
which these fail to fully account for
what's happening in a neural circuit as
it learns and I would go so far as to
claim that even if we knew the activity
of every single neuron in the relevant
circuit during some experience at this
point we'd be hard-pressed to
it using these rules which synapses
would change and which would so in
response to Mark's question of when do
we know we're there I wouldn't say we're
there if we got to that point but that
would be an important milestone that
would then let us go to ask well what is
the logic of those rules if we
understood the rules in order to be able
to predict which synapses would change
then we could at least be ready to go to
the next step so that's kind of the goal
the big vision today i'll tell you about
some progress we're making towards this
goal and to make this this general
problem tractable we've turned to this
brain area you heard about in the first
talk by Angus silver the cerebellum and
I could spend hours waxing poetic about
the advantages of the cerebellum for
studying learning but I will restrain
myself and just say that the circuit
architecture is relatively simple and we
know a lot about how neurons in the
cerebellum encode information at least
in the parts of the cerebellum that I'll
talk about and this makes it possible to
try to link events happening in the
world with the patterns of activation in
the circuit and the changes that are
occurring at synapses and connect the
dots between those different levels now
I'll focus today on the rules some
progress we've made in understanding the
rules controlling the recruitment of an
associated form of long-term depression
at parallel fiber to purkinje cell
synapses in the circle and almost 50
years ago David Marr and James Albus
hypothesized that these synapses are a
key side of plasticity during cerebellar
learning so this model still influences
a lot of the work in the field today so
I'll take you very briefly through it
there are two main inputs to the
cerebellum you already heard a lot about
the mossy fiber input pathway this
morning mossy fiber synapse on granule
cells that make the parallel fibers and
provide excitatory input to the purkinje
cells second input is from the climbing
fibers which arise in the inferior olive
and synapse directly on the purkinje
cells as well and the model is that the
purkinje cells which are the sole output
neurons of the cerebellar cortex that
fork in g cells represent all of the
different
sponsors you might want to make whereas
the parallel fibers represent all of the
different contexts in which you might
want to make those responses so by
modifying the appropriate set of
parallel fiber to brick in G cell
synapses you could learn to make the
right response to a given context and if
the coding in the parallel fibers is
sparse as Angus silver described this
morning then this would let you do
learning that's highly context dependent
which is the kind of thing we think of
the cerebellum as doing for fine control
of movement for example now the model
further hypothesized that the
instructive signals controlling
plasticity at the parallel fiber
synapses were provided by the climbing
fibers marrin Albus actually differed as
to the nature of these instructive
signals Mar thought they were
reinforcing signals that would
strengthen synapses that led to an
appropriate response whereas almost
thought they were error signals that
would weaken synapses that led to an
inappropriate response and it was all
buses error correcting version of the
story that's best supported by the
subsequent physiology that's been done
over the years if you record from
climbing fibers during a variety of
behavioral passed they seem to encode
errors and in brain slices activation of
the climbing fibers can trigger
long-term depression in the parallel
fibers that are active simultaneously so
this is an associative form of
depression that we described as anti
heaven okay so this morning I want to
talk about some of the progress we've
made in understanding the rules
controlling the recruitment of long-term
depression during cerebellum dependent
learning and this work has progressed by
taking advantage of the behavior shown
here the vestibulo-ocular reflex or v 0
R I'm very proud of my performance as
the are on our recent lab ski trip the
vor is a reflexive eye movement driven
by vestibular signals when your head
turns this movement is sensed by the
vestibular system which drives an eye
movement in the opposite direction so if
your head turns left your eyes turn
right and vice versa and this reflex
tends to
stabilize the direction that your eyes
are pointing in space as your head moves
about in the world and this improves
vision by stabilizing images on the
retina now in order to do its job of
stabilizing images this reflex needs to
be well calibrated and we study the form
of cerebellum dependent learning that
performs this calibration if for any
reason images are not stable during head
motion then the cerebellum dependent
learning kicks in and can adjust the
amplitude or sometimes the timing or
dynamics of the eye movements until
images are against table normally this
might occur during things like changes
in the strength of the eye muscles
during development or aging when you get
a new pair of glasses with different
magnification you need to adjust your
VOR but in the lab we can produce big
changes over short timescales by pairing
a vestibular stimulus head motion that
we control with motion of a visual
stimulus that we also control and
depending on the relative directions of
head motion and image motion we can
induce either an increased amplitude of
the eye movement response driven by the
VOR so if we move the visual stimulus in
the opposite direction from the head
then the eye movements need to be bigger
than normal to keep the image stable on
the retina and so over the course of
many such pairings of vestibular
stimulus with oppositely directed visual
stimulus there's a gradual learned
increase in the eye movement response to
that same vestibular input heed we move
the visual stimulus same direction as
the head then the eye movements normally
driven by the VOR would need to be
suppressed to keep images stable on the
retina and so over the course of
pairings of vestibular stimulus with
visual stimulus in the same direction we
see a gradual reduction in the eye
movement response both of these forms of
learning depend on the same part of the
cerebellum called the flock euless okay
so now I'm going to map this VOR
learning task on to the mark ito model
that i described we know that the
vestibular so we're pairing a vestibular
stimulus with the visual state bueller
input is encoded by the parallel fibers
parallel fibers excited
do cells which drive I movements the
goal of the reflexes to stabilize images
so image motion on the retina represents
what we call retinal slip represents an
error and that error is encoded by the
climbing fibers that are driven by this
image motion ok so here's how that looks
when we're actually doing the
experiments so we turn the head left
this is the angular velocity of the head
we turn the head left right that drives
an eye movement in the opposite
direction right left to induce base in
the VOR we move a visual stimulus
exactly opposite to the head this drives
a response in the climbing fibers and if
instead we want to induce a learn or we
move the visual stimulus exactly with
the head and that also elicits a
response in the climbing fibers and the
difference between these two training
paradigms is whether the on direction
for the climbing fibers the direction
that makes the climbing fibers increase
their firing is happening during head
motion in one direction which is it
subversive toward the side of recording
for VOR increased learning and the on
direction for the climbing fibers
happens during controversy of head and
movement during view are decreased
learning both cases if you follow so the
same climbing fibers encode the errors
during both kinds of vor learning if you
follow / kin G cells through learning
their responses change during learning
and they change so that their responses
get progressively smaller during the
stimulus in the direction that made the
climbing fibers fire and that's true for
both of these so we see changes that are
in the purkinje cells in the direction
that you would expect if the climbing
fibers are inducing a depression of
their excitatory parallel fiber inputs
so none of this is controversial these
happen to be recordings from climbing
fibers and purkinje cells in my lab but
it had been shown previously by a number
of different labs the results are
incredibly consistent and I would add
that these respond
ances of the purkinje cell drive and I
movement that is in each case more
controversy or less it subversive which
depending on whether it's summing or
inhibiting the normal VOR response can
give you either angry or a decrease in
ok so this all makes sense it could
plausibly be explained by climbing fiber
triggered depression of the excitatory
inputs it looks like ltd it smells like
ltd but the controversy that raged in
the field for decades is whether these
observations actually reflect the
induction of ltd if ltd is the mechanism
for these changes are in the purkinje
cells and the eye movements and so i'll
show you the in the first part of the
talk i'll show you recording stimulation
and perturbation experiments we've done
in my lab to try to resolve this using
the three main approaches available in
systems neuroscience we've obtained
convergent evidence suggesting that
under these conditions Ltd does seem to
be the explanation for these observed
but in this kind of training it does not
so the recording approach was conducted
by Hannah pain a graduate student in the
lab and she took advantage of
variability in the climbing fiber
responses to ask how tight is the
correlation between the occurrence of an
error signal and the climbing fiber and
the induction of changes in the circuit
so i showed you histograms the climbing
fibers on average respond when there's
an error but individual climbing fibers
respond on some trials and don't respond
on other trials even when the error is
present and so you might expect that if
the climbing fibers are what's driving
the plasticity then on the trials where
the climbing fiber fires you'd get a
little bit of plasticity in the circuit
on the trials where it doesn't fire you
wouldn't get plasticity and the fires
again you get a little bit more and this
is what Javier Medina and Steve Liz
burger in 2008 very beautifully showed
seemed to actually occur during another
form of cerebellum dependent learning
smooth they should
that they saw this tight correlation
between the occurrence of a spike in the
climbing fiber and the induction of
plasticity so we did similar experiments
and the way this works is with an
extracellular electrode we can record
two kinds of spikes and purkinje cells
simple spikes which are normal sodium
spikes that go at about 50 or 100 Hertz
spontaneously and complex spikes which
are a reflection of the climbing fiber
input to a purkinje cell I'll gets input
from a single climbing fiber and each
spike in the climbing fiber produces a
big calcium spike which we record on the
extracellular electrode as this complex
we get two signals for one we can see
the climbing fiber input to the cell and
how the cells output changes so we look
at pairs of trials and we choose pairs
where the climbing fiber fired on the
first trial and asked how the simple
spike output changes is there a
reduction in purkinje cell output as you
might expect if the climbing fiber spike
induces long-term depression and then we
compare that with trials where the
climbing fiber didn't find fire so we do
this during VOR learning in the
increased direction and we saw a very
clear change in purkinje cell firing if
the climbing fiber fired on the first
trial of the pair then there was a big
reduction in firing on the next trial
fraction you would predict from Ltd this
is similar to what Medina and Liz burger
had reported for smooth pursuit learning
so that all fit the model the controls
the pairs of trials where the climbing
fiber didn't fire we saw no change in
the purkinje cells output on the next
trial so this trial to trial change was
not an inevitable effect from giving
them some kind of training but rather
these changes seem to be happening in
tight coordination with the occurrence
of spikes in the climbing fibers okay so
all that fits the Ltd model but if we do
the very same analysis in the very same
cells during VOR decrease learning so
now we just change the training we're
delivering do the very same analysis we
got totally different results
now we see no change if the climbing
fiber fires we see no change in purkinje
cell and remember these are actually the
cells I showed you in this slide so the
climbing fibers are encoding errors
during both kinds of training the
purkinje cells if you follow them across
many trials are decreasing their firing
rate during the stimuli that made the
climbing fibers fire but in this case
these changes happening in a way that's
tightly correlated with the occurrence
of these error signals in the climbing
fiber and in this so that suggests that
this climbing fiber triggered Ltd is
contributing to learning in one case but
not the other but that's just one
correlation kind of approach we also
looked at stimulation so this is work
from postdoc RIA Kempo and graduate
student Jacob Rinaldi they said to the
extent that climbing fiber triggered ltd
or other plasticity in the circuit is
contributing to VOR learning we should
be able to bypass the sensory feedback
about errors and directly stimulate the
climbing fibers optogenetic alee to
roughly mimic how they normally encode
errors during learning and an induced
behavioral changes and this is
facilitated because the climbing the
coding of the image motion by the
climbing fibers is incredibly uniform
the vast majority respond to image
motion away from the side on which
you're recording so that allowed them to
go in and try to roughly mimic their
responses during learning and see if
they could bypass the air the sensory
feedback and directly induce changes in
the behavior so for these experiments
they use sinusoidal stimuli so the head
turns left right the visual stimulus if
we want to increase the view our moves
in the opposite direction and that makes
the climbing fibers fire during the IPPS
worse apart of the vestibular stimulus
if we want to decrease the VOR we move
the visual stimulus with the head that
makes the climbing fibers fire during
controversy of head motion so Rhea and
Jacob asked can we just get rid of the
visual
stimulus stimulate the climbing fibers
at the time they normally fire and can
we induce bo are learning in this very
direct way as a control so the way we do
it is test the VOR pair the vestibular
stimulus with climbing fiber activation
and then test in the absence of the
activation as a control we just omitted
the activation of the climbing fibers
this produces a non-associative
habituation our response over 30 minutes
but what happens if we stimulate the
climbing fibers at the time they
normally fire during training to make
the VOR bigger so a very robust increase
in the VOR relative to pre training and
relative to the control condition where
we didn't and this lasted at least two
hours after two hours the the
non-associative habituation decays but
we still see this very robust
associative effect of stimulating the
climbing fibers okay what happens if we
stimulate at the time that the climbing
fibers normally fire during VOR
decreased training aired with a visual
stimulus we can induce a decrease you
are well below this habituation control
but when we stimulate the climbing
fibers to try to make that happen we did
not get a decrease below the vestibular
only control in fact a trend towards an
increase and I'm showing just one one
kind of stimulation paradigm we used
which had three stimuli we tried less we
tried more we tried everything we could
think of I can't rule out that there is
no way to in stimulate the climbing
fibers and make the VOR decrease but we
tried a lot and we didn't find it okay
so that suggests that the climbing
fibers are not carrying the error
signals that drive you are decreased
learning that was from the recording and
the stimulation experiments we also did
took a perturbation approach and ed
Boyden was the first one to do this way
back when he was a graduate student he
asked what happens if we robbed Ltd make
elec you a genetic manipulation that
disrupts ltd
and one that EDD looked at that we have
now since looked at other lines but ed
looked at the cam k for knockout mice
these mice cam kinase boar is a kinase
that phosphorylates creb which has been
implicated in the late phase of
plasticity and many systems these are
results from David Linden's lab showing
that cam kinase or is important for the
late phase of cerebellar Ltd normally a
pairing produces a long-lasting
depression that lasts as long as they
can hold the cell but in these knockouts
there's an initial depression that then
decays back up to baseline so missing
the late phase of ltd ed asked what VOR
learning looked like in these mice and
he found that the acquisition of
learning in both directions was normal
the blue and and what the blue is the
knockout black is wild-type totally
indistinguishable but then if he put the
mice back in their home cage and came
back 24 hours later and tested retention
then he saw that the retention of the
learned increase in the VOR was
significantly impaired in the camp a for
knockouts now surprisingly to us at the
time because we were thinking VOR
increase in decreased learning was just
a matter of ltd on different subsets of
parallel fibers so we were very
surprised to find absolutely no
difference in the retention of the
learned decrease in the VOR so this told
us that whatever was supporting learning
in the two directions different
mechanism was supporting VOR increased
learning and suggesting that ltd
contributed selectively to learning in
that direction so there's a this
suggested a highly selective
contribution of ltd to learning in one
direction not the other but i'd also
found selectivity in another dimension
that was very striking so the results i
showed you so far we're done with
sinusoidal training and testing stimuli
at a frequency of one Hertz head turns
back and forth that one hurts visual
stimulus moves with or opposite we got a
very similar result if we went to a
higher frequency of two Hertz impairment
of the learn to increase in the VOR
but if we went to just a slightly lower
frequency the phenotype went away
entirely so I think this is was a really
important observation that ed made that
very subtle changes in the way that you
do the training or testing can determine
whether you see a phenotype or not this
is a change from one Hertz 2.66 hurts we
actually did one and point five and the
reviewers made us go back and do too and
something in between 0.5 and one so you
can see that there's this very sensitive
window where the behavior goes from
being ltd dependent to not and I suspect
but this could be the case you know so
I'm often asked well is the mechanism of
vor learning the same as eyeblink
conditioning or rotarod learning and you
know my answer is always well it really
depends you know the the mechanism of
vor learning is not necessarily the same
mechanism as vor increased learning that
there seemed to be multiple mechanisms
in the circuit that can produce a
similar behavioural outcome and which
mechanism gets recruited is highly
dependent on how you train and test so
there's a lot of talk now about how
results from mice fail to translate to
the clinic's I tend to think that I
wouldn't put all of the blame on the
mice I think it might really be in large
part are our mistake in the past of over
generalizing from one test of cerebellum
dependent learning to cerebellum
dependent learning in general or from
one test of amygdala dependent learning
to fear in general so I think we need to
be really careful about not over
generalizing our results and here's
another example so that was one this is
another line of mice that we've looked
at more recently this is under review
that also had perturbation of ltd and
showed the exact same phenotype that Ed
had seen highly selective perturbation
in these mice with disrupted Ltd of vor
increased learning at high frequency and
not vor decreased learning now and if I
look at other labs Chris disease lab and
Holland has done a lot of work on this
and sometimes he's reported
Ltd deficient mice have vor learning
deficits and sometimes not and that also
seems to fall out along the lines of
whether he tested at frequencies above 1
Hertz or below one hurts now you might
imagine that this is just reflecting the
fact that something about vor increased
learning at high frequencies is just
harder than the other kinds of you are
learning and whatever you do to perturb
the circuit you might expect that this
would be the first thing to go that's
not what we find so I just show one
example here we've looked at mutants of
the PQ calcium channels and they show a
very different pattern so they show
sparing a viewer increased learning at
high frequencies but impairment of low
frequency VOR decreased learning
impairment of the ability to modify the
phase of therefore you are so what we're
finding is that different subsets of
Methodism zar recruited by different
kinds of view are learning and you
really have to be specific about how
your training and testing if you want to
get the full picture of that mechanisms
contribution just to step back a little
bit and summarize this first part we've
known since the work of people like
Brenda Milner in the 50s that there are
different kinds of learning and memory
that depend on different brain areas but
I think most of us have been hoping that
when you look within a given brain area
that the question of how that brain area
learns would reduce to something simple
like consistent recruitment of a
particular mechanism cerebellar ltd or
maybe a small set of mechanisms but the
hope was that the same thing would
happen in that circuit every time it
learned our results from cerebellum
dependent view our learning suggest that
that's not the case there are different
mechanisms that can be recruited in
different combinations depending on how
you do the training so my lab is working
now to try to define what is the
taxonomy of cerebellum dependent
learning how many different components
are there and better understand the
rules determining when each mechanism is
recruited okay so the first part of the
talk I provided evidence that cerebellar
learning may or may not recruit this Ltd
mechanism that's the
so most textbooks in the second part of
the talk I mean the switch gears and
show you recent unpublished data
suggesting that the rules for induction
of Ltd at these parallel fiber to
purkinje cell synapses can vary across
different parts of the cerebellum that
the same anatomically defined type of
synapse can have quite different rules
be obeying very different rules for
plasticity and this is something we kind
of stumbled upon because we were
worrying about how the cerebellum solved
this problem that the error signals that
drive the learning are delayed so
parallel fibers activate the purkinje
cells which produce some response and by
the time the feedback about that error
comes back to the cerebellum there's
been quite a delay between the
activation of the parallel fibers and
the activation of the climbing fibers so
how can the circuit deal with these
delays using what we think of as
coincidence based plasticity this is
what theorists called the temporal
credit assignment problem so one
solution is suggested by what had been
shown about cerebellar Ltd previously
which is that there seemed to be a
pretty broad window for its induction
you can get Ltd with simultaneous
activation of parallel fibers and
climbing fibers you can get it when the
climbing fibers delayed a hundred or to
even 200 milliseconds you can get it
when the climbing fiber comes before the
parallel fibers and I'm showing these
results from Wade rigorous lab because
he makes this nice curve but across the
field many different labs have used
quite a broad range of parallel fiber
climbing fiber stimulus protocols and
shown robust Ltd so one solution for the
delay and the climbing fibers would be
to have pretty broad tolerance limits
for induction of the plasticity but this
didn't sit right with me because what we
know about cerebellum dependent
plasticity is that it supports these
incredibly precise behaviors we can
learn to time our movements to within
less than 10 milliseconds and I had a
hard time believing that that kind of
incredible behavioral precision could be
supported by a mechanism that seemed so
slow
so we think we found a resolution for
this mismatch oh this is just to show
evidence that in in the in vivo in the
vor circuit there does seem to be
compensation for this delay that's quite
precise so this comes from that
trial-by-trial analysis that I described
earlier and what I had shown you before
were results when we aligned on the
trial start which is what Medina and Liz
burger had done previously but we re
analyze the data aligning not on trial
start but on the time of the climbing
fiber spike so if you look at the time
of the changes in purkinje cell firing
relative to the time in the trial when
the climbing fiber spiked on the last
trial we saw that there was no decrease
in purkinje cell firing at the time that
the climbing fiber came in but there was
robust change in purkinje cell firing
about 120 to 150 milliseconds earlier
and this is very interesting because the
delay for the visual climbing fiber
response is on the order of 120
milliseconds so it seems like the
plasticity that's occurring in vivo does
not alter synapses active at the time
that the error signal from the climbing
fiber got to the cerebellum but at the
earlier time when the error was actually
being generated so in vivo it looked
like the cerebellar circuit was somehow
solving this temporal credit assignment
problem and we wanted to know what was
the synaptic mechanism for this just the
mismatch here's what we'd seen at the
synaptic level and here's what we needed
to account for what was happening in the
intact circuit so a very talented
postdoc Aparna super athan has found
what looks like a solution to this
problem and she did this by comparing
the rules for ltd in different parts of
the cerebellum virtually everything we
thought we knew about the synaptic
physiology of the cerebellum had
previously come from the vermis because
it's easy to slice but aparna wanted to
study synaptic plasticity in the flock
euless which is the part that supports
VOR learning
so she made slices brain slices from the
two parts of the cerebellum and she
started by using kind of a typical ltd
protocol in the cerebellum which is
simultaneously activate parallel fibers
and climbing fibers do that three
hundred times and if she does that in
the vermis she got exactly the same
results everybody else had reported
which was robust ltd she did the same
thing in the flock euless she did not
get ltd she got a very robust LTP and
this is in the cerebellum the LTP is
non-associated this is what you get with
parallel fiber alone so the very same
pattern of activation yielded opposite
changes in parallel fiber to purkinje
cell synapses measured in the vermis
versus the flock euless we had assumed
everything we knew from the vermis would
apply to other parts of the cerebellum
and that seems to have been a bad
generalization because there seems to be
very substantial regional variations in
the plasticity rules for the same
anatomically defined type of synapse so
we already knew we have the evidence I
showed you that Ltd seem to be
contributing to the vor so we felt like
these synapses should be capable of ltd
and we were wondering why they we
weren't seeing it and we thought about
whoops this delay but I mentioned that
when there's image motion on the retina
which is the error it takes about a
hundred and twenty two milliseconds for
that error signal to reach the
cerebellum on the climbing fibers and
this 122 millisecond number had come it
was something I estimated when I was a
postdoc in Steve list burgers lab by
using many different stimulus
frequencies and then looking at the
phase shifts okay so we thought about
this delay and tested the flock you
learn her low fiber to purkinje cell
synapses using this biologically
relevant delay in the climbing fiber
activation and then we saw very robust
ltd in the flock euless found that this
tuning for the behaviorally relevant
delay was incredibly precise so we saw
ltda if we delayed the climbing fiber by
a hundred
20 milliseconds if we delayed by only
100 we got LTP if we delayed by 150 we
got nothing significant but certainly
not depression for the students in the
room I should tell you that the way I
described the experiments is not how
they were done we tested zero we got no
Ltd we tested a hundred because it was
about 120 we got no ltd we went to 150
we got nothing postdoc pulling her hair
out I'm pulling my hair out and then
finally out of desperation we said well
why don't we try 122 we tried 120 and
and there it popped out assistance
Deborah pneus ok so it's it's highly
tuned and this is unlike this form of
plasticity that we found here at the
parallel fiber synapses in the flock
euless is unlike plasticity that i know
of any other synapse it's similar to
spike timing dependent plasticity that's
been described at many synapses in that
it has a very tight window of tens of
milliseconds for the the to pattern for
the two neurons to be activated but it's
unlike STD p in that FTD p is those
windows are centered very close to
coincident whereas in the flock euless
it shifted over a hundred milliseconds
from coincidence so it's precisely timed
to an interval that's over 100
milliseconds this ltd and the flock
euless also just to put it in
perspective compared to what we had seen
previously in the vermis and others had
seen so to just compare these these are
on different timescales this is the plot
i showed you before from the vermis
here's the flock euless if I just expand
this out to be on the same time scale
there's the difference okay so we found
this incredible temporal precision that
matched what you know many people had
seen that the behavioral level but what
was different than what had been seen in
the vermis we had a hard time believing
though that the Ltd and the flock
Ulysses temporally precise than the Ltd
and the vermis is not so we went back
and looked again to see if we could find
evidence for temporal precision in the
vermis and to do this we used a shorter
form of plasticity so that we could look
at the tuning of individual neurons so
analogous to the trial to trial
plasticity that I showed you in vivo we
looked for single the effects of single
pairings in a slice so we tested the
parallel fiber synapse we did one
pairing with the climbing fiber and then
we tested again and so we looked we just
used this ratio of the change in the
epsp after one climbing fiber spike like
we had seen in vivo that that induced
changes we found in the slice that this
also induced changes and in the flock
euless this single trial plasticity or
short-term plasticity have the same was
tuned for the same interval between
parallel fiber and climbing fiber as we
had seen for the long-term depression so
highly specific for the hundred and
twenty millisecond interval and we went
to the vermis and we found that
coincident activation gave us this
robust single trial depression we also
got it with a hundred millisecond delay
of the climbing fiber 120 150 it
depended on parallel fiber climbing
fiber pairing but it didn't like the ltd
that had been described before it didn't
seem to have temporal specificity when
we averaged across the population in
this way and that was the important bit
because when we then looked at
individual cells we found that the cells
that depressed for coincident parallel
fiber and climbing fiber activation
showed very little depression for the
other intervals and likewise the cells
that depressed robustly in response to
100 millisecond delay showed little
response to the other delays and so on
we found some that were tuned for 120
and some that were tuned for 150 so
although if you just average these all
together you get something that looks
like it doesn't have temporal
specificity that seems to be coming from
averaging across a heterogeneous
population of cells each of which is
tuned to a specific interval okay so we
have this model I mean before before a
partner started doing this work we
really thought you know that ltd was ltd
was ltd
but what partner is finding is that the
rules for plasticity at different
parallel fiber to purkinje cell synapses
seem to vary and we would speculate that
in the vermis like in the flock us the
cells might be tuned to the behaviorally
relevant delay in the flock euless it
was easy to show that because the
climbing fibers have such uniform
responses we know what the relevant
delay is the vermis is much more has has
diverse functions that have been
described we know there are climbing
fibers that come from the spinal cords
and reflects about sensory inputs at
very short delays in these same two
lobules in the vermis that Aparna
recorded imaging studies have reported
cognitive responses that you would
imagine would have much longer delays so
it's interesting to speculate that the
tuning for different intervals may
reflect the tuning of cells for their
climbing fiber delay okay so to
summarize I told you that synaptic
plasticity mechanisms are not as general
purpose as we had previously thought
that different mechanisms are recruited
within the same circuit during learning
depending on how you do the training and
that the plasticity rules at an
anatomically uniform population of
synapses can vary in a way that seems to
reflect their function I already
recognized most of the key players and
so I'll stop there and take questions